that is the song that Dolly Parton is
called her favorite coat of many colors
and it's easy to understand why because
it's about how her mom took care of the
family through to both time and that
story has been turned into a TV movie
now and only we are on the set with the
young girl he's playing a little dolly
but of course we had to speak with
dollar herself about everything that she
had to overcome eight-year-old Alyvia
Alyn Lind was handpicked by dolly set in
1955 Tennessee the partners were poor
but were surrounded by love and faith I
think my childhood made me everything I
am today I wouldn't take nothing from my
people I wouldn't take nothing for being
brought up in the Great Smoky Mountains
I've never been ashamed of my people no
matter how poor and dirty we might have
been you know I've always loved being
from where I'm from and having the folks
that I had back in the big dog horn and
the little Dolly Parton I think are very
alike because they're both sassy but
they're both sugar lends jennifer
nettles is Dolly's mom and Rick Schroder
is her farmer father who struggles with
his beliefs after his wife's miscarriage
everything's changed and I can't get his
balance he didn't read or write he was a
tobacco farmer he loved his family all
of all of them all the 12 kids
something dark had tried to steal our
joy dolly narrates and is an executive
producer on the film that shows the
strength she got from her country roots
this made me what I am
it's that spiritual base it's that
family love a family it's just that
simple life feeling what part of nature
marmalade